[Musica]
l'intelligenza artificiale negli ultimi
50 anni
ha prodotto una serie di tecnologie che
hanno cambiato drasticamente il modo di
fare tantissime attività umane nel 1980
fu il personal computer nel 1996
cominciò a diffondersi internet
nel 2012 ha cominciato a funzionare
le tele senza artificiale
non tutti in realtà anzi molti non
capirono all'inizio la portata di questa
innovazione per esempio cannes olsen che
all'epoca produceva la più grande
fabbrica di minicomputer
disse lo vedo una sola ragione per cui
uno dovrebbe avere un computer in casa
propria
paul krugman premio nobel per l'economia
e acuto editorialista disse in pochi
anni ci renderemo conto che internet
avrà un effetto sull'economia poco
superiore a quella dei fax
quindi se vedete queste innovazioni
avvengono apparentemente ogni 16 anni
cioè tempo che richiede la tecnologia di
maturare e quindi da qui al 2050
potrebbero arrivarne altre 2 ciascuna
delle quali con effetti dirompenti come
le precedenti
l'informatica a questo pregio cioè è una
disciplina che non ha limiti fisici
di altre discipline quindi non amo e
immateriale questo vuol dire che può
espandersi crescersi e svilupparsi
rapidissimamente e quindi solo limite è
l'immaginazione
alan kay per esempio immaginò per creare
il personal computer che si potesse
interagire con le macchine usando mouse
cioè indicando al computer cosa si
voleva con movimenti della mano qualche
anno dopo steve job penso che si poteva
usare un dispositivo
incorporato il dito come fanno i bambini
quando ancora non sanno parlare
e addirittura anni prima stanley kubrick
nel film 2001 odissea nello spazio aveva
pensato che si potesse usare un
telecomando senza batterie incorporato
cioè la voce
eppure ci sono voluti poi appunto 50
anni e l'avvento dell'intelligenza
artificiale perché questo si potesse
alla fine realizzare e infatti oggi
l'abbiamo intorno a noi l'abbiamo né gli
assistenti vocali abbiamo addirittura
nei robot aspirapolvere ma anche i
social media quelli che usiamo tutti i
giorni non potrebbero funzionare se non
ci fosse al loro interno tecnologia di
intelligenza artificiale e poi possono
fare anche compiti scientifici più
avanzati ad esempio
selezionare vaccini oppure interagire
con gli esperti in dibattiti su
questioni argomenti importanti e
addirittura compiti creativi per esempio
raccontarci gli eventi che avvengono
intorno a noi oppure addirittura
scrivere e produrre degli interi musical
per broadway
la tecnologia appunto si sviluppa in
maniera
veloce e
produce risultati sempre più innovativi
dove questo avviene molto spesso porta a
cambiamenti nel modo di fare le cose
e i benefici in questi molti campi sono
stati immense pensate semplicemente al
fatto che possiamo portarci in tasca
tutto sapere umano possiamo dialogare
con chiunque
possiamo lavorare ovunque e con chiunque
e questo senza intermediari senza
qualcuno che ci dice cosa dobbiamo fare
cosa dobbiamo scegliere quindi possiamo
fare a meno di editori di giornali che
scelgono le notizie per noi o di case
discografiche che scelgono gli autori
della musica che ascoltiamo o senza
agenzia di viaggio così via questi
settori sono stati rivoluzionati da
queste tecnologie
in realtà non è del tutto vero perché
questi intermediatori
di cui potremmo fare a meno sono
diventati sempre più invasivi e lo
possiamo verificare rapidamente se io vi
chiedo quanti motori di ricerca
conoscete utilizzate
probabilmente uno massimo due
quanti social network conoscete o
utilizzate
23 forse quanti negozi online usate
regolarmente anche qui forse uno e così
via quanti servizi di video streaming di
audio streaming di selezioni di viaggi
utilizzate puramente ciascuno di noi ne
conosce uno solo pochi e questo è un
fenomeno naturale che è dovuta al limite
di capacità di attenzione della nostra
mente e la difficoltà ad imparare cose
nuove
questo fa sì che noi ci concentriamo su
alcune cose soltanto e questo produce
anche degli effetti a con l'informatica
di accelerazione per esempio pensate a
luciano pavarotti quanti anni ci sono
voluti a luciano pavarotti per diventare
il tenore più famoso al mondo anni di
studio di preparazione di tournée
intorno al mondo per farsi conoscere da
circa 30 anni
cabile che io non conosco ma molto
evidentemente conoscono perché a 50
milioni di followers di queste reti
sociali con il videoclip sapete quanto
tempo ci ha messo per raggiungere 50
milioni di follower
tre
settimane non anni
cosa vuol dire che le aziende che
producono questi servizi popolari e sono
brave a sfruttare questi servizi
popolari crescono
economicamente e
finanziariamente a dismisura
adesso oggi tra le dieci più grandi
aziende al mondo otto sono informatica
ma non solo si espandono all'interno del
loro settore ma spesso si espandono
anche su altri settori qui ad esempio
abbiamo un'azienda che iniziata a
occuparsi di commercio elettronico poi
si è occupata di cloud computing poi di
produzione di video di streaming audio
poi di cibo poi di spazio e così via
robotica espandendosi in tantissimi
settori di vendola diventando un impero
tentacolare e se questo dovesse
continuare
avremo una concentrazione mai vista
inaudita di capacità economico
finanziaria nelle mani di pochissime
aziende è l'intelligenza artificiale
potrebbe accelerare questi fenomeni
questo produrrebbe disuguaglianze
crescenti
le disuguaglianze tra ad esempio tra le
grandi aziende e le piccole aziende a
cui vengono lasciate le briciole ma
anche tra paesi i paesi in cui
l'attività economica viene svolta e i
profitti vengono trasferiti attraverso
meccanismi di paradisi fiscali in altri
paesi
oppure tra gli stessi lavoratori i
lavoratori di queste grandi aziende
tecnologiche sono coccolati sono pagati
con stipendi da rockstar e sono loro che
producono e sugli strumenti che
controllano che sviluppano le
intelligenze artificiali o le macchine e
poi ci sono dall'altro lato i lavoratori
della cosiddetta gig economy cioè quegli
operatori che vengono operano agli
ordini delle macchine per esempio quelli
che trasportano il cb nelle case o altri
prodotti nelle nostre case
quindi queste disparità possono
accrescere sì con intelligenza
artificiale e
questo anche perché
costruire strumenti modelli di
intelligenza artificiale di sta
diventando sempre più costoso e
complesso per esempio il modello di
linguaggio naturale più potente al mondo
che in grado di parlare in tantissime
lingue
è costato circa 4 milioni di dollari ed
è composto di circa 175 miliardi di
connessioni tra neuroni
il cervello umano è ancora 100 volte
superiore il numero di connessioni come
di dimensioni però è probabile che la
crescita di come si diceva velocissima
dell'informatica ci porterà questo a
queste dimensioni
nell'arco di dieci anni poi vedremo
gli altri 20 anni che seguono avremo
sistemi ancora più potenti del cervello
umano però i costi saranno tali che
forse solo pochi se li potranno
permettere e quindi bisogna pensare che
potrebbe avvenire tra in questa
evoluzione
considerando quali sono le forze in
gioco
nel mezzo c'è il nostro pianeta il
pianeta con le risorse naturali ma anche
con le risorse umane risorse che sono le
nostre competenze nostre passioni i
nostri desideri e le nostre opinioni e
da una parte ci sono le aziende che
sfruttano queste risorse verso il
profitto e la crescita e dall'altra i
cittadini che forse sono interessati più
alla sostenibilità e all'uguaglianza
in questa dinamica tra queste forze
avverrà
cambiamenti dei prossimi anni
e quindi bisognerà decidere in che modo
mantenere questo bilanciamento per
evitare che avvenga una rottura di
questo equilibrio a favore dell'uno o
dell'altro
il
una direzione possibile è quella che
abbia il sopravvento il mondo il modello
economico della crescita indifferenziata
indiscriminata e questo potrebbe portare
a quella che è una situazione distopica
in cui le aziende assumono un potere
enorme al di sopra diciamo di qualunque
altro potere
economico politico e determinano tutto
quello che deve avere avviene nella
nostra società
il
questo questa evoluzione
l'automazione e la portata
dell'intelligenza artificiale
crescerebbe sempre di più il lavoro
diminuirebbe l'aumento della automazione
corrisponderà progressivamente una
diminuzione del lavoro e si rischia
arrivare un punto in cui non c'è più
sufficiente lavoro per riuscire a
consumare tutto quello che viene
prodotto una situazione di stallo
dell'economia è uno dei fenomeni che gli
economisti hanno ipotizzato è studiato
ma non hanno una soluzione non si sa
cosa succederebbe a quel punto sono vari
scenari di tipo economico che sono tutti
quanti molto
estremi e di difficile comprensione
ma alcuni esperimenti sono stati fatti
ad esempio con con i topi mettendo una
serie la comunità di topi in un
territorio in cui hanno a disposizione
cibo volontà e non hanno bisogno di
procurarsi il cibo che succede alla
popolazione per un po crescere poi
comincia ad accrescere alla fine si
estingua fenomeno completamente
imprevisto quindi senza lavoro la specie
si estingua
quindi come si fa a contrastare questa
possibile deriva che viene portata dallo
sviluppo tecnologico della tecnologia e
del consumo di risorse indiscriminato
bene abbiamo da una parte le aziende che
crescono
verso la crescita e profitti e
dall'altra ai cittadini quindi da una
parte abbiamo delle multinazionali
che operano al di fuori diciamo delle
delle strutture
delle nazioni e dall'altro abbiamo i
cittadini che invece sono all'interno di
nazione è la loro voce può essere fatta
senza farmi sentire attraverso la
mediazione attraverso molti livelli di
mediazione e fanno fatica a farsi
sentire
per esempio abbiamo visto da diversi
movimenti che oggi cercano di
sollecitare la politica a prendere
azioni rispetto ai cambiamenti climatici
ma si limitano a dire alla politica fate
qualcosa ma la politica non può fare
molto perché
incastrata tra
interessi contrastanti l'uno con l'altro
quindi quale può essere una possibile
soluzione io faccio una ipotesi
visionaria cioè di dire abbiamo le
multinazionali che sono operano facciamo
delle multi comunità che contrastino le
forze del
mercato con le forze dei cittadini cos'è
un utopia un'utopia era considerata una
comunità ideale in cui le persone
vivevano in situazioni ideali
oggi possiamo creare delle utopie
virtuale in cui le comunità sono formati
da cittadini che vivono insieme davvero
in comunità virtuale possiamo usare la
tecnologia per costruire queste queste
comunità in cui le persone operano e i
principi e le regole di queste utopie
sono quelle scelte dalle persone stesse
quindi sono mondi virtuali se volete
costruiti con la tecnologia in cui le
leggi però riflettono quelle che noi
desideriamo non sono leggi che vengono
dalla storia dal passato non dobbiamo
continuare a litigare l'uno con l'altro
perché abbiamo bisogno diversa ogni
utopia si sceglie le sue e cerca di
svilupparle nel modo migliore possibile
a quel punto saremo liberi di scegliere
potremo verificare quali sono le
migliori e le peggiori potremo essere di
tutto pie basate a per esempio su
principi ambientalisti oppure per
esempio religiose per esempio la
comunità degli amish è una comunità
religiosa che rifiuta la tecnologia
oppure possono essere basati su visioni
un umanitarista o viceversa visioni e le
tariffe di società fatte in caste
la possibilità di crearle queste queste
utopie consentirà loro di svilupparsi
dare forza alle persone che vi
partecipano
le utopie le comunità operano davvero
sono operative e operano in nome del dei
loro aderenti e negoziano con le altre
entità che siano aziende che siano altre
comunità altre utopie in modo che la suo
sviluppo segue i loro ideali e loro
principi saremo quindi più liberi e
potremo fare orientare l'evoluzione del
mondo verso la direzione che che
preferiamo
quindi gli ho illustrato le potenzialità
dell'informatica e dell'intelligenza
artificiale che è una sua componente
sono cose meravigliose vedremo risultati
straordinari già oggi per esempio
vengono pubblicati circa 200 articoli
scientifici al giorno sull'intelligenza
artificiale ci sono idee dentro
meravigliosa se avessimo solo il tempo
di leggere
questi vuol dire che le prossime due
rivoluzioni che informatica che
avverranno ci porteranno a cose
straordinarie però importante vedere
come queste rivoluzioni tecnologie dove
ci porteranno le precedenti sono state
portate alla disponibilità di tutti i
cellulari li abbiamo tutti internet
l'abbiamo tutti quindi invece c'è il
rischio che queste tecnologie
rimangono appannaggio di pochi
quindi il nostro obiettivo dovrebbe
essere quello di democratizzare
l'intelligenza artificiale e così le
successive tecnologie questo due scenari
uno è abbastanza probabile che succeda
senense nulla avviene come si diceva
riguardo al cambiamento climatico se non
facciamo nulla quello avverrà la
catastrofe lo stesso avverrà in questa
evoluzione della tecnologia portata agli
estremi della crescita indiscriminata e
la super concentrazione tecnologica in
cui si formano delle mega strutture
tecnologiche che controllano le persone
quindi anziché preoccuparci dei robot
che dominano le persone dovremmo
preoccuparci di queste strutture che
invece usate da uomini per controllare
altri uomini
quale direzione prenderà il futuro
dipenderà soltanto da noi dalle nostre
scelte e quindi vale la pena di
ricordare ancora una volta quello che
diceva alan kay che il modo migliore per
prevedere il futuro è di inventarlo
grazie
[Applauso]